va poursuivre la discussion avec benoît
gagnon et les criminologues et
spécialiste en sécurité informatique
bonsoir ce gagnant bonjour alors quand
on pense pirate informatique on pense
souvent à des gens qui vont s'attaquer
au gouvernement au pouvoir
laon révèlent les données de millions de
personnes qui n'ont rien fait d'illégal
qui ont peut-être vous avez été infidèle
ou voulu être infidèle mais rien
d'illégal pourquoi quelle est la
motivation du groupe team n'impacte pas
d'accord puisque le team n'impacte pas
vraiment fait de coups au par avant les
rumeurs persistent en part par contre
ils sont à l'effet qu'il y avait
quelqu'un qui était dans la compagnie
avait deux médias qui est responsable
ashley madison et donc répète trouver
des choses n'ont été coupe uteck était
tout simplement un employé mécontent
donc l'on peut penser que peut-être une
vengeance personnelle avec les
dirigeants ou bon bref les scénarios
sont ouverts pécule mais valide parce
que ça arrive assez fréquemment dans les
gens savent peut-être moi mais il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont des
compromissions de données
c'est suite à des interventions
malicieuse la part d'employés ou dans
ses employés qui sont mécontents donc
c'est ouvert mais c'est une piste
intéressante
il a en plus il ya des gens qui se
ferait extorqué d'autres pirates
informatiques utiliseraient ces données
là maintenant pour extorquer certaines
de ces personnes étant donné que les
données sont ouvertes sont maintenant en
ligne
ils ont été ré exploiter à des gens qui
ont déjà construit des nouvelles bases
de données qui permet de les exploiter
contacté ce genre là par exemple ben moi
je sais que ton nom se trouvait là je
vais contacter sa conjointe ou ton
conjoint puis à l'autre aussi des
entreprises qui veulent rentabiliser sa
main nous on sait que vos données
existent on les a classés il ya des gens
qui disent on cherche et on peut vous
aider à vous protéger moyens naïve damas
rétribution faire de l'argent est-ce que
c'est pas une preuve de plus que la
sécurité informatique vraiment est un
leurre aujourd'hui c'est un gros
problème
disons le en fait tout ce qui est fait
par l'homme peut être défait par l'homme
et puis si vous mettez des données
personnelles sur le web et c'est clair
qu'il faut s'attendre ce qui
éventuellement
ça soit un problème qui est un problème
de sécurité et c'est pas nécessairement
des gens mal intentionnés il s'appelle
tout simplement des gens qui font une
erreur
il ya beaucoup de compromissions de
données qui sont fait suite à des
mauvaises manipulations de données en
fait c'est plus fréquent que du piratage
donc oui si vous mettez des données
personnelles sur le web
j'ai pensé qu éventuellement il va avoir
une compréhension ce qui est un paradoxe
parce qu'on demande de plus en plus de
mettre des données sont l'ouest des
faits vous avez juste à regarder les
sites web que les gens utilisent au
quotidien
le nombre de fois qu'on vous demande par
exemple de vous créer un compte de vous
connecter à ce conte choix pour
commenter faire des des commandes d'être
chanteur
bref ça fait en sorte que oms et des
traces qu'on laisse et puis c'est des
données qui sont éventuellement qui
peuvent être attaquées ou simplement
avec laquelle il peut avoir des
problèmes
ce gagnant merci beaucoup merci à vous